views and abundant powdery snow in the
french alpine resort of flynn
but few visitors or skiers to enjoy
either
the french government's decision to keep
lifts closed across the country
until at least the end of february
because of covid has dealt a crushing
blow to the winter tourist industry
and its workers frederick gassner has
relied on the ski season in flynn for
work for nearly two decades
this year he was supposed to operate a
lift instead
he's unemployed
we just don't understand at all resorts
have put in place special sanitary
measures against covid
so that people can come but we're told
we have to stay shut
financially it's catastrophic for all
the workers
the government says that opening lifts
would encourage crowds at a time when
cases of the more contagious coveted
strains are rising
but without lifts skiing is out of the
question for most
only the very determined hike up for a
downhill run
the alpine ski industry is the backbone
of our winter economy
it's hard for us to survive without the
lifts and the economy linked to them
of course we have other sports like
cross-country skiing and sledging
but 90 of our february income is from
skiing
without it we'll make half that this
would normally be peak season here in
flynn the resort would be
packed with tourists many from abroad
and these slopes
would be busy with skiers and
snowboarders instead
it feels eerily empty on the main square
restaurants and bars are shut to under
covered restrictions
this hotel is one of the only ones open
but the manager wonders for how long
as the government is considering a third
full lockdown
we just need answers precise deadlines
so we can organize
because we have 30 seasonal workers here
and we want to know if we'll have enough
work for them until the end of the
season
we're not complaining about the
government's decision but we need to be
able to plan
months of uncertainty little business
and a looming lockdown
people here say resorts like flynn will
need government aid to survive
without it tens of thousands of workers
will be left out in the cold natasha
butler
al jazeera flynn